Yes,
art is sweet,
Miss guitar,
everything
is
fine, come on, come on, me, tell me, heh, is
that program today an integration test?
[music]
today
ana
[music]
is Mr. Kobayashi
Hmmm,
may I disturb you today?
I entered Toru Eto, who told me that I could live in the
old days.
And then,
a,
my cousin's crew, I
can't put in the
words I want to start with
.  But
I don't intend to hire people.I
won't get in. No, that's the problem, right? Stand up and
lie down.You can shoot Yoshinoumi here or kill him
.
true
ah
yes
r
I'm sorry
I made a promise that I can't keep but I want you to understand that I can't keep
it 6 Haa
I'm sorry  Toko Crew
[Music] The
guilt won't go away It's not a
dream If it was
n't a
dream
[Music]
Someday Ben Tobe Lou
Maybe I should come to the collection
[Applause
] First of all, let me show you how Kyoya's maid should
be.  If you don't start from 1, then
house maids are good
at that
.
May  It's a customer service. Please wait. It
's something to deliver. Please give
me a stamp.
If that's the case,
it definitely won't suit Mr. Kobayashi's taste.
Dosu Girl
[music] I'll study from
a store that even has the basics as an aid
Please tell me what you don't like about
this
By the way, I hate
eggs without you.
I know I was killed by using things, and I think it's an iPhone.
Alcohol, women, achievements, and things like
that aren't the same as humans
.
I was saved by Mr. Kobayashi.
So I was raised to return
even stupid humans.
I think
it's good Hmm, we're probably the stronger dragons It's a
song to bring on the weekend It's been a rough time lately
It would be safe if we could protect this house
If you get a phone call, I'll tell you to answer it more
Oh yeah, this is the phone
If you pick it up when it rings and play like this, you won't know what to do next Okay,
Buber
I wonder what you were
doing I asked Mr. Pahlir  Kill
those who try to steal the lumber. Kill those who are in doubt.
Kill them with a
curse.
come on
[music]
game
ya ah ah ah ah I'll protect you ah I was in the middle of the 5th inning I'm home
how was it tonight
I won't go out for a drink today, Tatsuya-kun Well,
I'm sure there are other women out there who will invite me Kobayashi-san is like a male friend
I
'm a maid who lives with Kobayashi-san every day.
She's a relative's child and I'm dealing with her
.  I didn't say I was going to
seduce you, you can choose, it's
a spirit 2 true A drink at the end of work is
the best  It's tough to go through
[music]
I'll show you how close Tadashi
Kobayashi and I are.
I wonder if the developer will notice if I don't point it out.
I'm sorry, I
'm sorry I can't get into this kind of story.
Hey, hey,
hey, I'm a
maid,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh  Go ahead, dolls and other maids Level 1 cosplay It's
like a foreigner doing a ninja samurai Come on, I
admit the cuteness of the Gothic Lolita flow, but it's local neatness and hiding the opponent
Noda student day camp Lolita and maids  It's expensive. I should be more careful about mixing up one part of a room.
I don't really understand why Rutan's horns in cosplay.
Sun
Nyandana
[Music]
I'm sorry, I'm
drinking with Kobae-san. I'm drinking to talk about maids
.  Ah,
oh
, you drink too much, so
you love Mr. Kobayashi, right?
I
told you before, don't lick the laundry Lotte
Yes, from now on I'm going to condemn Mr. Kobayashi directly.
I checked the inside with my clairvoyant ability
.
You always wear the same clothes, do
n't you?
I do
n't want to say thank you,
Mr. Kobayashi.
Come on,
amaran Hi, how tall are you
?
4 I understand how to find out.
It's been a
long time since I
've been giving you strength  It's not a matter of being clean and dirty Yeah
, you bought Nidhogg, right
?  Yeah, how do you feel because you took a bite?
Oh,
I feel like there's something left behind
.
I don't think I can dry my laundry
Where do you think the pie is?  But I want to sleep with Mr. Kobayashi.
I wanted to say, did
it hurt when you
were stabbed?  Please tell me something,
maid,
you're talking about me,
right?